- She's my answered prayer.
- I feel like a (beep).
- Oh, daddy's money, trust fund baby
and that is not us at all
- We gotta transfer money now
like we gotta pay for things.
- Yeah.
- I want you to be on the same page as me.
- [Motoki] Welcome to Stacks, the show
where every vote counts.
Today, five couples must
decide who gets to take home
one thousand dollars.
(Cash register chimes)
The players will have
four rounds of discussion.
After each round, there
will be blind voting.
One gold brick equals one vote.
At the end of the game,
the person with the tallest
stack wins the prize.
This
is Stacks.
(Cash register chimes)
(Upbeat music)
Can I get a woo woo?
- [Group] Woo woo!
- I didn't think that would actually work.
For round one, each player
will get one gold brick.
They'll have six minutes
to discuss who they
think should take the cash prize.
Voting will be explained at
the end of the discussion.
Ready, set, go.
- [Ashley] Who's married?
- We're married.
- We are too.
- Ryan and I are both full-time students
so we don't really get
to see each other often
and if we do, it's like to the dining hall
that's our date.
- What school do you guys go to?
- USC so tuition is pricey.
- We were like, "Oh, like their
parents help them out."
- "Oh, daddy's money, trust fund baby"
and that is not us at all.
- We got married during 2020
when everything was shut down
so we couldn't really
have our wedding ceremony
so that's the reason why we would
want the money is to
be able to spend time together
and also contribute to our wedding.
- Pretty much just wanted to
put the heat off of us.
- Yeah.
- And just put it
on everybody else and we just, yeah
stayed in the background and
people wanted to vote for us then
we would just win.
- I'm getting really emotional
but this year has just been
really challenging for us.
I have school loans and
things have just been piling up.
- And I actually left my full time
job last year and so we had to tap
into our 401K and now
all that is depleted.
So we are just in a place where we're just
anything would help.
- My parents went through a
really brutal divorce about two years ago
and since I was fifteen I've had to
work thirty-six plus hours
and go to school full time.
I think the reason why we deserve it
as a couple is because like, because
of how much I'm working right now
and how much school I'm going through
it's really hard to see my boyfriend.
- It'd be nice to kind of
get a little getaway
and like do something.
- My wife's actually a nurse too
so we know what it is, like she graduated
the first thing she experienced was COVID
for the past few years.
So not being able to
spend time each other,
I totally get it and then
we weren't able to use our honeymoon money
because we had some family
in the Philippines we had to help.
- This is gonna be hard.
- I know!
- I wish we could give everybody like
- Can we multiply this?
(Group laughs)
- All right, time is up everyone.
It's time to vote.
Each couple will vote for
who they think should win the prize.
But there's a catch.
If all five couples vote for themselves
the game is over and no one wins.
- [Niko] I think they
have valid hardships but
I think all their story is
just our story combined.
(Suspenseful music continues)
- His mom is in the Philippines, yeah.
And she was a nurse during 2020.
They deserve it, they deserve it.
- We both come from broken homes,
divorced families and so we want to
make sure they feel
blessed with this money.
- I really felt for Charlie and Amber.
I thought their story was really touching
so that's why I voted for them.
- Yeah.
- I think everyone voted for themselves
and we didn't want to vote for ourselves
and have the game end
and I kinda liked them
so
they were cool.
- [Motoki] Open your eyes.
(Suspenseful music)
So there you have it.
- Oh! We have a brick! That's nice!
- Yeah.
(Gold clinking)
- Ready for round two?
(Group exclaims)
In round two, only couples who currently
have stacks will receive two
more gold bricks for voting
but all couples can
participate in the discussion.
Ready? Go.
- We're probably gonna vote
I feel like we can see our story in
all of your stories, right?
We're probably gonna vote for you guys
the nursing thing, my
wife's gone through it,
that's really difficult
and then Charlie and Amber, we've had to
go for our savings, family's
very important, right?
So important that when
we flew her grandma home
I had her part of the proposal for us.
She made a video for Ashley.
- He brought out the video
and I was like, 'Oh yeah, that's'
- He was prepared.
Yeah.
- Just about us
we were recently in an accident
so just recovering and
doing physical therapy.
- Thank God you guys are okay.
- Thank God.
Our car is totaled so.
- That is, y'all are good.
Standing here
with these gold bricks.
- Yeah.
[Mycah and Charlie Laugh]
- We want our credit score to eventually
you know, get up there
to be able to get things!
- Kind of going along with like the whole
health care thing
I am currently PRE-PA right now
so hopefully fingers crossed
once I graduate from college,
I can go to PA school
but that's going to be a lot of money
so this would hopefully help
at least towards tuition right now.
But
- I really want to have
an argument with someone,
but it feels like it's not going anywhere.
It feels like all we're talking
about is just life story
and I really wanted it to be a kick!
- Because of the divorce
that happened to my mom
and my dad, I was actually
forced to help my mom
pay our mortgage and that's like
totally cool because like now I have
a great home and I'm in a
healthy living situation
with my mother.
I've had to like ask Francisco
to like lend me money to
help like pay the mortgage.
I appreciate him so much
because the fact that when
like things get, really do get rough
I always have someone
to like fall back on.
- [Motoki] For this round,
couples can use their
two gold bricks to vote for any pair.
Even those without a stack.
(Suspenseful music)
(Suspenseful music continues)
- Their story really
touched my heart because
I know how hard it is to
struggle financially and want to help
your mom and dad.
- They're voting for us and we want
to, you know, mutually represent.
- I want them to keep playing
and I love them!
- We really resonate
with Charlie and Amber so
we love you guys.
- [Motoki] Please open your eyes.
(Suspenseful music)
(Gold clinking)
- When I'm sitting over there
I feel like I'm like one of those rich
(beep) in Squid Game.
(Group laughs)
Like I'm wearing this and I'm like,
'Yeah! Battle for this part.'
(Group laughs)
Okay, so round three,
we're kicking things up a notch.
We're actually gonna be
deciding who you want to
lose their stack.
- I do not have the heart to do this.
- Ready and start.
(Clock beeping)
(Group exclaims)
- Everyone started.
- I like that we have Ryan Tiffany back.
(Group cheers)
- Can we all individually go around
and say what we would use the
money for like immediate type thing?
- We recently signed a
new lease near our campus
and the money would just be best spent
on paying the, our first rent together.
- For us, we would probably
try to get a new car.
- We were planning on splitting
whatever we got leaving this.
I think I would use the five hundred to
add an extra payment onto the
mortgage of what I already pay.
That way, this next month
with work, I can save
up for my paying for my next
classes for next semester.
- We've been there. We've been like,
'Hey babe, you gotta transfer money now
like we gotta pay for things.'
- Yeah.
- You know, like,
did you get paid?
- Tapping into my savings.
- Yeah, we really do want to go
we used our money for the lola
we really do want to go on our dream
honeymoon vacation.
Because at the end of the
year, we plan to start
a family and try to make a baby.
- I'll just keep, try to keep it quick
but I just know one thing
for certain, this is
this today is happening for a reason.
Just hearing each of
you, we lost our lolas
and y'all have we wanna
keep your lola healthy.
We were in a car accident in 2017 and
the Lord kept us safe
- Our car was totaled!
- We were in school
we know what it's like to struggle
and you guys, we come from broken families
divorced families.
We know how painful that is.
We would set aside some money
to learn about investing
because the reason our parents
got divorced is due
to financial struggles
and we want to like, we
feel like it wouldn't be
right if we got a thousand
to just keep it ourselves.
So we would set aside
money to give to everybody.
- Couples who currently
have stacks will vote
for who they think should
lose their entire stack.
(Suspenseful music)
(Suspenseful music continues)
- If we win, want to give some,
some money to everybody like
we're gonna get everyone's PayPal
and so hopefully nobody voted for us
so we can keep it moving.
(Suspenseful music continues)
- I just feel like it
wasn't an immediate need.
- I think everybody might've voted
for Niko and Ashley.
We're all here for one thousand dollars
and I want to go for it, you know?
- And we love them!
- Reveal your eyeballs in three, two, one.
(Beeping)
- End of the day it's cut throat
they went for us, like I get it
you know what I mean?
- [Motoki] Niko and
Ashley lost their stack
but now have the opportunity
to redistribute their bricks.
They can give their bricks
to any couple who they
think are deserving.
(Beeping)
Pretty even spread but
looks like Abe and Francisco,
you have one more than everyone else.
- I definitely didn't expect everyone to
listen to our problems.
(Gold clinking)
- It's the final round.
You have two minutes of discussion.
However, I'm not gonna tell you
what the voting rule is quite yet.
Get going.
- So do you guys wanna say
something like personal?
- I think we should all be strategic
like kind of be like
- Well that's pretty strategic.
- That's strategic? Okay,
then we'll go for that.
- It's emotional appeal.
- Okay, Abe has always wanted to go,
well, has recently been wanting to go
like to the snow and like the
mountains and stuff like that.
- Besides rent, I don't know
probably just somewhere else
other than the dining hall
for a date.
- We actually couldn't find it
within ourselves to vote
for any of you guys.
So we voted for ourselves.
So when we say we're
gonna wanna distribute
amongst all of you, we really mean that
and we're on camera on record
wanna get everyone's PayPal.
If we eat, everybody eats.
- Yes, that's really great
but we're kind of here to compete.
- I agree, yeah.
- Like have one winner.
- Our car is completely totaled
so we do need to get something new
and thank you guys for your votes.
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- No worries.
Yeah, we love all you guys.
We wanted you guys to do well.
Trying to start a family
at the end of this year
so just wherever we could
afford to that thousand
that might be like three tanks of gas
but who knows who know?
Who knows what it's gonna be right?
Yeah.
(Group laughs)
- Okay, so here is the final voting rule.
For the final vote, each couple
can move one brick from any stack
to another. Only couples who currently
have stacks are allowed to vote.
(Suspenseful music)
- I don't know!
I thought it would be better to move
from one who has the
most to give it someone
who doesn't have any.
(Suspenseful music continues)
- I want you to be on the same page as me.
I don't want to take from them because
they want to buy a car.
- Yeah.
- They need a car.
I don't want to take from them because
they want to buy a house.
I want to take it from the people
who say they want to go to dinner!
Do you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Please open your eyes
in three, two, one.
- Oh wow!
(Group gasps)
- So as you can see, we have a tie.
- I, I was shocked. I was really shocked.
- Charlie and Amber, Abe and Francisco.
Here's how it's gonna work.
The two couples will have 30 seconds
of discussion. At the end,
each couple must move a brick from
one of the tied stacks.
If there's another tie, the game is over
and no one takes home the prize.
- I don't want it to make it sound
like your problems are less than ours
but I do think that we deserve
the money a bit more just
because we don't have like any
extra help from anyone else.
My dad's not involved in my life.
His parents work full time
to support his other four
siblings and it's just
him supporting himself.
- Yeah, I think the main thing is
we wanna be able to help everybody.
I was actually calculating it in my head.
I'm like, okay, if maybe we
could do a hundred, wait, no
maybe we could do one-fifty per couple
and although that might not
be a lot, we wanna still
be able to help everybody
with a little something at least.
- Because we know you guys deserve it
and everybody here deserves something.
- You can only take people
for their words so long
and like, I don't really know them.
So, but they seem like
really great people.
(Indistinct whispering)
Option one
they took one of ours and
put it there, we tie.
Option two
we take on of ours,
put it there because they took one
and then they supposedly are going
to split between everyone
and then take some for themselves.
Either way, they'd be taking home
more than everyone else.
We need the money!
(Suspenseful music continues)
- Because they deserve it,
they deserve it, they deserve it.
- [Motoki] If there's another tie,
the game is over and no one
takes home the prize.
All right folks, please open your eyes
in three, two,
one.
Open.
(Suspenseful music)
(Group chuckles)
- Oh my.
- So unfortunately there was another tie
and no one is leaving with any money.
I feel like a (beep) too, but
(Group laughs)
- I was like, people are
gonna take home zero because
- Yes
- They both had situations
where they needed the money.
- We were so hoping that Abe and Francisco
Tiffany and Ryan, Shaun and Mycah, Niko
and Ashley could all have
something at least something.
- I don't wanna get emotional again,
I think it's because
I'm starting my period.
(Charlie and Tiffany laugh)
- Like when I was just sitting there
and watching all these couples come in
they were like dressed to the nines.
Like "Dang, okay so they're
probably like stable jobs, stable income,
and then you hear their stories
as the game goes on and
you're just like, wow
we're all more alike
than I initially thought.
- All right y'all,
thanks so much for watching.
I have an angry mob behind me.
Unfortunately, no one won today
but I get to keep the thousand dollars.
No I'm just joking
(Group laughs)
If you enjoyed
please
like this up, comment.
Thanks again, y'all. Appreciate it.
Give yourselves a round applause.
(Group applauds)
See you next time.
Stacks out.